DAWS AT THE
OTHER END. THE FAR WING OF A BE
SET UP.
AND A CASH IN BY
HE WILL FORCE IT TO BESMITH.
TIED UP BY BENIERS, AND GOOD TO,
RIGHT IN TO THE DANGER ZONE, A
BOQVIST, SCORES.ANDING OUT IN F.
ALL IT TAKES IS A COUPLE OF
ROLLS IT FREE AND HE WILL PULL .
>> HE WILL HAVE AWAITING IS HIS.
AND HERE IT FULLY EXTENDED
OVER, HE GETS A GOOOO
THE EBERLE.
DROPS IT TO NO ONE IN
PARTICULAR.
JOHNSON HAD IT CHANCE.
THEY SCORE!NOUGH TO
SOUCY, TO THE OUTSIDE, OFF THE
TWIG OF DONATO.
COLTONSHOT, THEY  OFSOUCY, AND
GIVE HIS STICK TO THE
DEFENSEMAN, RIGHT HERE IS THE T
AT THREE.SCREEN WIDE.
THEY HAD  HOKIE KEEPS THE ZONE
DONATO, HAVING A CAREER SEASON
COMES DOWN SLOWLY, HE GIVES A
GOOD HEAD FAKE. DRAFT CHOICE.